all right Eric and Karen yes where you
guys from originally where'd you where'd
you grow up uh well for me uh that would
be Orange County Fullerton you know grew
up there and went to high school uh
Sunny Hills and
me oh yeah
me was in La Puente I used to uh it was
El Monte and then I went to La Puente
suburbs of La yeah and if he wants it
you guys are married yeah 13 years
legally
how'd you end up down here you're at
Sixth and Crocker which is one of the
worst
probably streets locks you could be on
you're probably only two white people on
that block right yeah no we are and uh
we get hated on all the time
but every night the whole story
um was at the beginning of this year
uh see I'm an electrician I was getting
tired of getting screwed by all the
contractors I actually did a building
right out here on Hope called King Cigar
Lounge a lot of rich people there lots
of rich people I'm between 11 to 12th
it's beautiful you did all of it but I
got tired of getting screwed by them
so I went off on my own
and since I was doing that I had all my
tools everything my life inside of my
car at the beginning of the year I got
stabbed in the back
uh by a gentleman that was a uh
uh black Nazi literally or figuratively
literally yeah the swastika on his hand
everything
looks like a Nazi too
red laces everything he's uh you can
tell it's
don't understand
so on
all my tools
everything mistake
everything not just our tools but the
most important
things that we needed he had just gotten
them back to he had lost all his tools
from another contractor that kept them
and he'd given them to his workers so he
had just came up with all his new tools
and lost it again and the car so
so that that made you for young streets
um well the stabbing I'm sorry I got a
little this after I got stabbed lost the
car uh it got left there uh I had no
keys no way to get into it and
we weren't able to pay rent with our
brother-in-laws and my mother-in-law
well they don't want to put in for
utilities or any rent whatsoever
so
we weren't able to pay rent for I
believe about one to two months and my
mom was getting real stressed out and
she uh took it out on me mostly she
always does and
one day we just got into and she's like
leave you know like tonight so we left
and we heard that they had a lot of
um programs down here you know to get
housing and we're like we're tired of
renting the family and
you know we deserve our own spot
yeah yeah we do and we've tried many
times
um but you know what it's it's a lot
things are a lot closer out here
than they are
um where we where we were in West Covina
or La Puente you'd have to go you know
say go to the DPSS office well that's 30
40 minutes away and then to go to
another office that's another 20 minutes
yeah so
it's down here you have everything right
here right in your face and there's a
lot more opportunity that I had never
even heard of until we came out here
so it was really neat
um we knew some of the people coming
down here and we thought it was you know
I grew up since I grew up on the streets
since I was 12 I didn't anticipate it
being like this
that's for damn sure
so tell me about your childhood era
uh my childhood yeah how'd you end up at
the streets at 12 years old oh well my
parents were uh extremely religious they
were Christian and then they decided one
day that it would be a fantastic idea to
convert to Judaism
yeah you know they took me out of I no
mind you I was in a
a private uh private school private
Christian School
at in second grade and third grade is
when they decided hey you know let's
let's be Jewish what the hell why not
you know so they sent me to public
school
which was kind of backwards but all
right but they um
made you wear the yeah
um they made me wear yonko and
it's um
it really messed me up just all the kids
making fun of me and trying to start
crap with me
um
I'm sorry I just there's so much
it's all
well from there
um they just they they sent me off to
boarding school out in Missouri
and uh for 13 months I didn't know
whether I was going to be there forever
or not
but um they didn't even visit him
you know um
you know I guess I was being bad I
wasn't the best kid you know I take off
for a while
but that was also because I'd have to
sit there and for simple things like
do you eat pepperoni pizza I'd have to
sneak out of the house
you know he was secluded from a lot too
they kept a lot from him
so when he you know their time don't do
this but never why
so he'd be curious so when he actually
explored and seen certain things that's
when he went all out because
they kept no no I'm just
oh yeah that's cheering up I'm sorry
Karen no tell me about your chocolate
um I am
the only daughter from Six Brothers
and I was
more like the caretaker in the family
than anything she babies my brothers
more so
um
abused you know by my stepdad
in my way
yeah I'll just beat him up like
physically
sexual
emotional
you guys know how long ago
did we
oh [ __ ] like 13 years you're talking
about how long ago was abuse or we met
no what time how long ago did you guys
meet oh we met um
we met 13 years ago on July 17th July
7th
um
20 2009 met on MySpace of all places
uh it turned out to be a joke uh well
one off as a joke uh friends were all
trying to get at her
and uh I was in the band at the time
touring uh just messing around and
um
I didn't know that she had added me the
day before but I I just messaged with my
buddies like hey watch let Daddy show
you how it's done
you know I was like I bet you I could
get her with one word
and uh it was hi smiley face you know
because I know how my buddies were they
were hey you know they want to get drunk
and party and this and that and it's
what everybody else uses you know but I
was genuinely interested and I try and
show that
yeah just tired
but that's that's how that started uh
three months later she was pregnant
yeah and um
then we got married after that you've
been married for how long now 13 years
now 13 years yeah we we no kids we we uh
one kid he's 12 years old the most
wonderful beautiful boy in the world
he's uh
God he's I couldn't ask for a better kid
we couldn't have you know where is he
he's with uh her mom right now we don't
want him down here
you know it's um
it's hard being this
far away from yeah and drugs were part
of your life back then oh yeah they
always have been
and your drug now is fentanyl correct
how did that start for you guys
oh well thanks to me
thank
you I kind of got turned on to it
oh thank you I appreciate that
um
because you're always so pretty
yeah don't worry but um
you know he had a complicated birth
um but he's he's healthy healthy and
he's very smart you know and we never
lied to him about anything we may
uh omit
some details
but we're honest about everything
whatever he wants to know we we did the
exact opposite of how my parents taught
foreign
how much do you blame the drug addiction
for your situation today
in all reality
I know it has some part but I don't
blame it and I know most everybody would
disagree it's gonna be all but it's not
I'd say it'd probably be
25 percent
or less
you know
um I've always been a functioning addict
as Hershey you know never neglected our
responsibilities nothing just just like
how we talk now yeah it's just we used
to feel normal
because we don't have time to withdraw
not right now
have you ever gotten clean or tried yeah
we have yeah it's more like a guinea pig
test out here
um the Wesley Center
they uh I think we were their first
fentanyl clients yeah yeah because they
didn't know
the nurses doctors didn't know how to
spell it properly I had to help them
with that and
um when they did that they gave us a
a couple boxes of it but you know we
waited the correct amount of time
there's different I don't know if you
know anything about it but there's
different analogs of of the fentanyl
it's called remifentanyl sulfentanyl
acetyl fentanyl car fentanyl yeah
um good God there's there's a ton so
so what happens is some of them will
last a little bit longer until they'll
stay in your body a little bit longer
which you know
um
it's just good feeling numb sometimes
yeah
I am
I had a above you know that's not me
bragging it's just an explanation as to
why one of the reasons why I do it aside
from liking to feel good and um
is that it
it slows down my brain um you know I got
a high IQ as a kid
um and I remember my Mom calling them
what a couple years ago I'm just saying
you know we're all out of the blue oh
you know what I think there's a reason
why you have your anxiety disorder and
this could be why and there's a link to
people with extremely high IQs
um to suicide and to just driving
themselves crazy they're gonna stop
thinking you can't turn it off yeah so
it's
it drains him he's always in his head
always
can't turn it off you know I'm always
thinking about what can happen what all
the different outcomes all the different
possible outcomes that there will be or
could possibly be so that that way I'm
not God forbidden not attracting them
but I'm trying to just so I know
what to to be prepared for you know
you'll have a backup for his Backup
backup for that backup in the back back
up to the backups backups backups
backups you voted
I have she did that that almost killed
me that um
what emotions do you go through living
this lifestyle
you're living here
how do you make money
well we're just trying to do it the
right way just selling things we don't
steal we don't
we like to um I'm sorry baby no go ahead
go ahead
um we we like to try and you know we
never sell our bodies or anything like
that we we have our own pressure too
right oh yeah there's people that have
told me to try and pimp my wife out
because others do you know and they get
mad at them because he doesn't here it's
crazy because they think
that I'm for everybody like they're like
oh like how dare he not let us you know
sleep with his wife like it's weird
their mentality
so they get mad at him and since I'm not
doing what they want now they get mad at
me so they hate us both
and we've been attacked
multiple times multiple times we've been
jumped um
you know and uh a lot of people say it
wouldn't boil down to race
but that's [ __ ]
it does come down to race you know
that was actually the first thing that
my mom our closest friends down here
um Family it mentioned that you know
we're gonna be tested so it's gonna come
down to race
everybody else we talked to say no no no
no it's not gonna race you know it's
just this it's just that
because we don't do anything to
disrespect anybody
we keep to ourselves yeah we just try
and keep our head down you know it feels
like not bothering people bothers people
yeah and it does I I don't understand it
we have a crowd of people that literally
sit
across the street from us all night and
talk [ __ ] all night as if they're trying
to push my buttons to have me blow up
and go and kill every single one of them
they try to separate us as much as they
can like they try to have us fight they
want us they don't want to see anybody
happy
since and you know I'm sure they're
betting too like oh how long they'll
last yeah that's what I always say is I
bet there's some kind of a pull going on
but um you know it's they always try to
separators yeah I'll turn my back for a
second and some of you will already be
trying to get in my life
you know somebody's already tried
drugging us both and raping us the only
thing I can thank God or whatever the
hell else
you know atheism or whatever's out there
um is uh that we have a high drug
tolerance so they get mad we've had
people try and Drug us and we watch them
and sit there and they start getting
upset and they're like yeah go ahead and
smoke and you relax you know and then
we're we're smoking we're fine we're
like you have a very high tolerance yeah
extremely it makes us laugh though
because yeah we see them getting upset
they're like oh you're smoking all of
our stuff I'll go ahead and get on you
know yeah so so how does this like I
asked this before how does this
lifestyle affect you emotionally
oh very it's a roller coaster to say the
least we argue more very very very much
more
um things have kind of gotten a little
physical not punching or anything but
you know we've shoved each other once or
twice just you know not even meaning to
Once one of it was she had accidentally
bumped me like it like kicked me but she
was just lifting her leg over and I got
upset with that
and so I shoved her leg back and it's
something that we've never done before
you know with everybody at your throat
and conspiring to kill you not to
mention with
the Cubans
talking every day about kidnapping my
wife
it's it's draining I stay up every
single night I I don't think
um what was it uh just the beginning of
the mid last week I started finally
sleeping again
I have insomnia normally but um
I stay up all all night long all day try
but I can't Germania
but um they you know they don't seem to
grasp the fact that she's Mexican she
isn't White
you know
Jalisco so people from at least go have
light skin you know green eyes blue eyes
um that fighter Canelo or Canelo is from
Australia he's got
um
was it a light skin and that's it brown
now is that Ginger yeah yeah so
yeah you know they they don't think we
understand what they're saying because
Cuban the way they speak is a lot
different yeah different dialect we get
different yeah different dialect or
different ways like key words and key
phrases still are very
pronounced you know like don't lose
track of her yeah don't lose her or oh
what the the weather the blonde girl
like I I understand better than I can
speak it's around us like when we walk
by even the their wives will be like you
know like even though their wives are in
on it yeah and we already know that
they've been in on trafficking kids
you know I don't even know if we should
say that I know you know to hell with it
you know they need to get caught it's
horrible what they do you know
especially since they've gone after my
wife you know as bad as it sounds like
somebody's tried killing them but it
seems like they never get them like
there's been a lot of I don't understand
why the evil Thrive and yeah just
because we I have a drug habit or she
does doesn't necessarily make us a bad
person we're not hurting anybody we we
make sure to keep it out of the face of
yeah we don't like doing it in public
like how some people shoot you know I
don't like smoking what is it that keeps
you here on Skid Row you could you could
go someplace safer or trying to get a
housing
and these are the only friends that we
have the the three that we could
probably count two or three that we can
count
um you think you have friends
um
let me think
I I honestly I would say they're very
very very good acquaintances yeah I
don't ever want to get that confused
again
because we're very sensitive you know
emotionally wise
yeah God that sounds like such a [ __ ]
thing to say but that's how we are we're
very sensitive you know um
we're in tune with each other but we you
know we're very personable you know not
a social not I guess a social butterfly
kind of right like people approach us
everybody
that's something approach us we don't
approach anybody we try to keep rapists
everybody that approaches us as bad
intentions
and um but we've learned you know
anybody that comes up to a straight up
and says hey man you know what my name
is so-and-so you know I keep it 100 you
know I'm I'm I I don't do this to people
I don't do that I don't do this and me
and her just kind of look at each other
and kind of smirk and we're like oh all
right yeah on to the next one bye dude a
lot of them will make up
places they've seen us just to talk to
us like
yeah exactly remember me we've had
people stalk us and they put it so
General to where it could be anything
you know hey we use that guy at the bus
stop sitting next to that guy with the
face yeah yeah the guy with the face
yeah did he have a nose hell yeah he had
a nose oh yeah I remember you like kind
of crap like that like what I've learned
after doing this for
it I've been down here for 12 years but
the last three almost every day on and
off
Liz when somebody tells you who they are
and what they were going to do that's
basically a list of who they aren't and
what they're not going to do yeah yeah
absolutely almost almost to the to the
to the team yeah
there may be one one slight variation
but that's that even then that's a maybe
yeah you know they're practically giving
you a grocery list of what's yeah they
they tried uh raping us with the draping
us or her mostly you know who knows I
would remember with that gorilla piss
sure the the PS PCP all right
um you know they put in a cigarette and
we could see these two people that were
one of them was their first neighbors he
was so calm and cool and collected I
never ever would have thought he was
like that but then his name is his
nickname is demon and what we learned
here is what they call them is what they
are like it's not just you know it's not
just
yeah you know now I'm a they call me
rooster because my last name is ruse I'm
also a dick or a [ __ ] you know like but
I'm not you know I got red I had red
hair and all that and it but but you
know his name he's a demon yeah and he
does evil things what's your biggest
fear down here
um losing her
anything happen to her I wouldn't be
able to
I wouldn't be able to live with myself
I'd probably go on a I'd probably go
postal
it's been the hardest
experience toughest thing that you've
had happen to you since you've been on
the streets
um sounds like you've been through a lot
the hardest
um not being by her son yeah and um
just
having to readjust
to for me you my son putting my wife In
Perpetual danger not putting her in
there but just always that and having to
reacclimate myself to being back on the
streets again it's it's different when
you're by yourself
than when you have the most important
you know say you're carrying around the
whole diamond
you know that's gonna be nerve-wracking
because you don't want to drop it you
don't want to chip it nothing you don't
want anything to happen to it not a
finger I don't want anybody touching her
and that's
how it is for me it's um
any regrets
it's a tough one
I don't regret doing dope
I'll say that right now that's just who
I am that's everybody has their advice
some people like to drink their beer
some people like to go shopping some
people like to do that I believe in
moderation and I've shown that you know
that's the one thing what we're not down
here for but my our regrets
procrastination and letting my anxiety I
don't know if it's the same with her but
letting my anxiety
paralyze us from doing what we're
supposed to do
you know we
get so scared of what's unknown or what
you know what I can't control that's my
biggest yeah
I have to be in control you know not of
her but just
you know like he likes to plan the day
and it never goes the way you plan
so he's I'm trying to get him to just
learn to live day by day you know just
when we get done we get done and we just
try to stay busy
well I I procrastinate on so much that
we could have had so much more done by
now you know
um like our taxes we needed to get
finished up but we just had all of our
stuff stolen our important information I
mean go for it take it dude what are you
gonna make my credit better but somebody
actually did that too yeah yeah someone
did but
um you know it just it sucks you got to
go get it all over again and we're just
trying to do it if I would have started
at the beginning when I had originally
planned
ship it would be loads better
yeah the people get in the way and
people you know trying to put a wedge
between us trying to separate us and my
anxiety
on procrastinating a lot of guys that
always come and try to make him look
weak you know which I don't see it I
make I see them this week
because they think
I want money and you know I mean who
wouldn't want to stabilize but they're
like oh I got racks of money I can get
this and that that's also the way that
lady we need to think too
is we need to think it put ourself in
that just like the the secret says is to
put ourselves in that yeah
the abundance you know the 48 Laws of
Power and the secret have been
phenomenal in helping us and just
reviewing that
um
you know I always read survival stuff
but yeah it makes it we realize what
we've been doing wrong too
you know it'll point out exactly what
we've been doing wrong what we see
others doing to us
you know exactly and it's
[Music]
um
you know it's a giant learning curve we
just try we're trying to stay positive
we're trying to look at the Silver
Lining and everything you know it's very
hard like this morning when we got up
ready to give up this morning
she wanted to leave
I don't want her to leave but I want her
to be happy but you know we gotta stick
it out and it's just because these
people are just
relentlessly hard and
they're just relaxing what did you guys
say is the most important thing you've
learned
in your lives
there's a couple number one would be
communication
between each other
you know uh just the overall life
communicating with each other because
how are we supposed to fix anything that
you know that I'm doing wrong or that
she may be doing wrong when and I may
not know
that he's doing it real because I don't
tell him
and um out here patience patience
patience and trying to stay positive
putting a smile on your face it's very
hard
you know especially when you're the
minority
you know I thought I thought it was when
I went out to Indian reservation in New
Mexico with my buddy
you know he was the minority but this is
a whole different you know if you could
survive here that's that's what we're
looking to try and get out of that you
know we can survive anywhere I can pass
this down to my son like I've done
everything else I just like to pick and
choose what
I passed down to him make it
age-appropriate that's what we do for
our son is we don't lie to him we just
keep everything age-appropriate we never
had to ground him since he was two
but that's the biggest thing is just
let's look for Silver Lining and learn
from it
and
yeah
all right
Eric and Karen thank you so much for
sharing your stories yeah I'm sorry it's
a little scattered and yeah
I'm very emotional yeah appreciate the
best of luck out here thank you hey
thanks man I appreciate it brother thank
you